we got a lot of ground to cover peter
because we're going to do a draft of our
defensive player of the year candidates
and there's so much in football morning
in america we could ask you about but
i've got one specific question for you
because you spoke to the commissioner
and you asked him specifically if he's
dispirited that was the quote about the
fact that colin kaepernick remains out
of football more than three years after
he became a free agent goodell said
those are club decisions i've encouraged
teams to evaluate that and sign him if
they feel that's the case now
i locked on to that because i was
standing next to you six years ago
before the week one game in seattle when
you reported that when michael sam had
been cut by the rams the league was
actually calling around encouraging
teams to sign michael sam to a practice
squad
how do we reconcile the reality that if
the team re if the league really wants
to get a guy employed they know how to
do it with this kind of hands-off
approach they've taken to colin
kaepernick
because what roger goodell would say and
what he said to me uh you know that i
didn't use is basically we tried to set
up a workout for him last year for all
the teams it didn't work out as
everybody knows blame whoever you want
on that
um but mike i think you make a very good
point
look
do i know for a fact
that someone in the league office called
the rams you know late in the draft
and and asked them please would you take
michael sam no i don't know that that's
what a lot of people believe happened
but i don't know that okay but
they clearly wanted michael sam to be
drafted no question about it yeah now
if michael sam uh in the event of
seeing the links they went to with
michael sam i'm sure if you ask this
question right now to roger goodell he
would say what do you want us to do we
set up a a tryout forum and obviously
behind the scenes i've told people that
hey listen
and i have no idea what goodell has done
but i believe that he has
asked some people in the league i don't
know this at all
but i believe he's done more than sit
idly by as it relates to colin
kaepernick and but it's still a black
mark for this league
that colin kaepernick
and whether he ever plays again or not
it's a black mark for this league that
none of the 32 teams or say 31 after the
49ers has at least offered him a
contract
after the denver broncos tried to do
something
uh early in 2017 to bring him on to the
broncos all right so like gut feeling i
mean it's is it over for you
i mean two things peter one are you
shocked that he didn't get more play
here with the current environment of you
know the social injustice in the nfl and
then two what's your gut say like is it
over
or or
are we going to continue to hear it i
have no idea chris who would
after after an off season like this and
not getting signed
and now going on to the fourth year
fourth season without playing football
i i i can't imagine
anybody i mean look we're talking about
alden smith right now he hasn't played
football since 2015 and everybody's
saying wow can he come back at age 30
after flaming out for five years and
obviously rushing the passers a little
bit different than playing quarterback
so to me
i would be surprised if he ever got
another shot
and i think that passage with time makes
it easier and easier for the teams to
continue to run and hide and i think
once we get through this season and get
to the four-year anniversary of the last
time kaepernick played it will be over
it will be done if it isn't already
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports